welcome to the program for the first
time last night's the Titan games
premiered on NBC and to be on Thursday
nights at 8:00 Eastern Time in part
starring Dwayne Johnson and the person
to my right from ESPN Carrie champion
good to see you good to see you thanks
for having me
so of course so let me just start with
this one how did you get your start in
the television business you know I was a
local news reporter remember local days
course my very first job was in West
Virginia Bluefield West Virginia mine
was Redding California was a one-man
band which is popular again they called
him mm Jays now but I shot my camera I
edited my video I did all of my own line
all on deadline in West Virginia and I
was going to be I mean I had it in my
mind I was gonna be Katie Couric then I
was gonna be Oprah and then that was it
I was gonna be a star you know right so
which was it ABC NBC what was it it was
WOA why and it was an ABC affiliate I
was KRC our television okay ABC
affiliate how much you make an hour six
oh there's a great story so I start
started in 1994
and I got 650 an hour look at you
okay okay hold on a second so three
months into my tenure KRC our television
spirit of the North State which was the
was the I guess the logo of the the
slogan of the station I get called into
the office by my news director fella
named Cal Hunter Haim and he slid across
the table he folded up piece of paper
with a staple at the top and said go on
and open it and I'm like oh my god I
have no idea what this is gonna be so I
sure enough I'm a nervous cuz like why
is he calling me and I open up the top
so as not to disturb the staple I open
it up and it said congratulations your
probation period is over I had no idea I
was on a probation first of all and I
know how to raise and he filled in one
blank for 650 to 670 whoa an hour whoa
20 cents an hour whoa good
relations okay what was your first
worries your start well I I really want
to tell you that you were making more
than me and I started a little later in
life than you did but I remember every
week my check would be somewhere every
two weeks sorry yes will be somewhere in
between 375 and 450 three hundred and
seventy-five dollars
and four hundred and fifty dollars and
whenever I did a great job my my boss
was like we're gonna give you an extra
little bonus and he gave me twenty five
extra dollars for them look at that yeah
he was a kick you take this here carry
and you don't spend it every so how did
he SPN find you I then you know so I
went through the local news rankings my
last job was in Atlanta where I got
fired to rehired for maybe cursing on
air I said mothersucker
cuz you know that's a very urban thing
to say but they thought I said the
f-bomb okay
yeah and they were mad at me so they
fired you and then you got my job back
because there was no actual audio of me
cursing and then so ok I think I was
just a pain last you were a mother son I
was a mother so they were like this
woman ok and then so I loved fair and
then I end up working at the Tennis
Channel which is a you know single
support network and then from there I
had this great idea I was like I should
go work at ESPN yes and then that
happened however here's a story and you
can relate to this right I I didn't know
anybody there so we had this great idea
to fly out to Bristol Connecticut and I
was gonna knock on doors and I had a
meeting with a guy who was really nice
and he said I really want to hang out
with you his name was Jerry Madelyn no
do you know Jerry hi so GMAC meets with
me for five minutes he forgets that I
flew all the way from LA and he goes oh
my god we can't send you on your way let
me just gather up some meetings for you
and he gathered some folks for me to
talk to Lynn and then you know six
months later a year later rather if I'm
just honest they were like there's this
show called First Take do you want to
host it and I was like what show I was
like the show with the guys and then I
was like well what do you mean what do
you I don't understand because it was
just confusing to me they had a host
there's Dana and there was Jay yes and I
was like oh okay well sure I'll come an
audition I go to audition and you know
you're not get out the part yes I killed
it if I do say so myself
how did you know you killed him well
because they weren't talking but that
was that that was the key
and skip they do it with you yes they
were doing with me but they can and you
know skip was very honest he was like
there's no real way to do what we do
because it's just magical and it's just
on TV he's also throwing crap against
the wall just in case it's it's it's
anything to do with LeBron so then he
goes we try to do the show right I we do
a fake version of the show right and
they were just so pleasant and polite
they weren't arguing and I was like this
gentleman okay that was your first first
take okay and then I did great and then
you know they hired me and then I was
like welcome kid I was a rook it was
hard sure yeah so I went the other way
I went from ESPN to a 1 sport network
which is great you know and and I
remember I did knock it out of the park
with my Sports Center audition and the
reason why I did is I stayed in the
Radisson Hotel across the street you
remember that yeah lovely place that one
season across the street from from ESPN
and I stayed up all night because AI
couldn't sleep B anytime somebody went
to the bathroom in the room above me I
heard them and see I I was watching
SportsCenter with Dan Patrick and Keith
Olbermann and I'm like you know what
just to get myself into the audition for
the next day I'm gonna watch them and
it's getting inspired and fired up sure
enough the next day my audition for
SportsCenter used the same tapes just to
date myself the same tapes and same
highlights from the night before so I
had no idea I was actually legitimately
studying for my audition the night
before yeah so I was not nervous
I knew I was doing things in my own head
saying if I was doing this highlight I'd
say this oh wow
so I got it done and you killed it and
then I was hired and I was on
SportsCenter in 1996 and then a couple
months later I was paired up with a good
friend and a colleague of mine and yeah
it's somebody who I know you know as
well who carry champion here on the Rich
Eisen show I'm gonna turn a little bit
here it was four years ago today that's
two past yeah Stuart Scott who I did
more TV with than anybody in any SPN
I know I know you're tearing up I do too
yeah you know I so what what is your
recollections of of Stu so when I first
started working there and everyone has
this story so I'll try not to try to
keep my emotions in check oh good I mean
he was really special so when I first
started working there I had to work on
that show first take right it was really
it was a tough show and I didn't really
know you know I don't know what I was
getting myself fooled you were thrown I
was and they were like figure it out and
so a lot of people would just kind of
ignore the toughness of it and that
place is a lonely place if you're not
from there you know and I mean I'm kid
from Los Angeles and I and I'm living in
Bristol Connecticut and I'm figuring it
all out and and I and I figured out sink
or swim I think I figured it out
but there were days where I was just you
know I wasn't feeling it and I never I
never really complained because no one
cares I hum but one day I had a really
tough day on air and I remember thinking
to myself okay I don't know how long I
can stay here I don't know if I can do
this this is tough this is this isn't
stretching me beyond my skill set and I
remember doing a commercial break and I
just thought I was saying it to myself I
lean over I just grabbed my phone cuz
you check your cell phone as we do
mm-hmm this a TD so I check my cell
phone and there is a message from the
one and only Stu and he was like while
you're dealing with all of this stay
elegant and classy and above it all
you're doing great kid I almost lost it
on air but is that not him come on come
on right
is that not who he is and then when we
knew he was really really sick when we
say we cuz everyone knows right we all
had this conversation one time and it
was when Jamel and Michael were working
and we were sitting at our local bar
there in Bristol we were just kind of
you know we kind of knew what was coming
and we all wanted to talk about how
great he was and then we would all we
all put out our phones because if he
sent you a message you would save it and
each one of us had a very special
personalized message from him he told
you Mel you're the only one that does
that dude that can do what you do don't
ever forget that you are the best
he told Michael I'm so proud of you I
loved watching that mean they we were
reading these messages for this man and
he didn't just do it for me and for
Jamel and for Michael he did it for
Cassy Hubbard he did it for Kevin he did
it for everybody
he was so generous and so caring about
this about us this group of talent and
he knew he knew what we were going
through but he didn't want to get into
the minutiae of it all he was just like
keep your head up yeah cuz he I think
that's a great way to put a carry
champion here in the Rich Eisen show
because the minutiae the reason why I
think he probably want to get into it
with you is because that's you can get
caught up in all that point no yeah the
point is to be yourself
yep that's the point and that's what he
was saying to every single one of us
stay yourself that's right because he
the number of times that he was told
about the minutia
yeah he just discarded it uh-huh and he
was himself
I lost track of that and I was
inspirational to me to knowing how much
he was going through and the thing that
I cannot believe yeah are the number of
Stuart Scott I don't want to use the
word imitators because i'ma take a bunch
of people up on TV
yeah from when I grew up but people who
he is clearly inspired and now you don't
bat an eyelash when somebody's dropping
some form of hip-hop lyric during a
broadcast or does something completely
personal that has nothing to do with pop
culture's racially it's just themselves
you put it out there he was amazing he
was he was like the definition of
authenticity and it was he made me
comfortable being myself on air there
right because that's the only way you're
going to be able to truly affect people
and connect with people and be personal
and and some people don't believe in
that and I believe in that
wholeheartedly and he encouraged
everybody to do that yeah my wife and I
looked at each other were like can't
believe it's been four years yeah well
because you know I met my wife in
Bristol oh did you yes I did okay you
know she well you know all about again
you know about what your social life
could be up there and I met her up there
and she just wanted to be friends hi
Stuart he'll always be pushing the two
of us together to hang out oh yeah I can
see that oh yeah yes playing matchmaker
when you saying you know hang in there
too
he's telling her you know hey he's not
so bad and you know and Stu would always
be just you know and I just seen the way
he is with it he was with his daughters
you know as inspires me with my little
five-year-old I mean not to get too deep
here obviously even though we are yeah I
just it's you know there's not many
people who obviously know him so what I
think for so many people is the
invaluable time so you've got to be on
air with that that Legend and I would
have killed to do that I would have
loved to have a show with Stuart I would
have loved it Terry champion here on the
Rich Eisen show well I you know it's not
a bad man if you will consolation prize
to have a show with Dwayne Johnson I
mean what does he do again yeah I know
he's kind of you know what one would
call a international juggernaut yeah the
Titan games which began last night on
NBC what is it like to be on the set
with with Dwayne Johnson this day and
age here now I remember everyone prior
to actually starting the show we I was
you know how we do the auditions this is
our business right that's all anybody
who can relate TV goes in for an
audition and you you talk to the
producers of the show and from what I
could tell what I could glean the show
was about just sweat equity just about
working hard everything I read about him
everything I've seen him do you can tell
he's a hard worker because he's never
not working you know never not working
but I respected that and the idea to
meet when I walked in they said well
what do you think the show is about and
I said I think it's just it's about
people like us who just really want to
work hard they may have had a dream
deferred they may have had a missed
opportunity on any level whether they
played sports in college or high school
or maybe they thought one day they'd be
a pro at whatever it may be and it
didn't turn out that way
but they used their physical grind to
build them up and and figure it out and
I was I admire that because that's all I
know right especially in this business
you have to work really hard you can't
get by on looks you can't get by on just
pretending as if you know what you're
doing you have to put in that work and I
was I was excited about doing the show
like that but most importantly you know
everyone knows his story he has seven
bucks in his pocket he came here and I
think he has a little more than seven
dollars in this perfect
five dollars of the $7 no and working
with them was just that he never stopped
he had energy non-stop Pleasant I was
told everyone had to be nice so I put a
sometimes I can get cranky rich
especially at 3:00 in the morning
but he kept everyone having a great
attitude and then obviously lemic you
know him and golden boy they were great
too because they were just beyond
professional it was such a great group
of people but even better it's really
about these stories these stories are so
inspirational people say also why is
this show different from the other shows
the other competition shows this because
it's the stories the stories move you
you tune in every single week and you're
like I'm reading for that you're already
rooting for somebody you're like I like
that person I love what she's went
through I love what he went through and
it was just special
I wouldn't you could feel it on the set
because it's overwhelming he gave me
anxiety watching them compete yeah plus
the the competitions are are created by
Dwayne Johnson's his work out based on
some of my workouts - is that right
which one which one based on your work
and there's this one where you're
lifting like my as I drink my wine yes
there is this one I'm kidding there's no
you know okay I love wine me too
okay good what kind me to a big booming
Cabernet but really a Brunello is my
favorite that's my go-to
okay so which okay what is a give me I
used to love mail me but it was really
sweet what was your favorite which one
you say it was you're using the past
I'm sorry currently from last night as a
matter of fact so you mean in terms of a
drink you're consistently oh gosh the
consistent go to that I'm doing right
now cannot Brockman while I come across
as what will I come across as if I'm
very specifically highfalutin okay okay
you know I'm hard you can be fancy
there's a something called Tenuta rosa
right now that is a Montepulciano wine
by the way okay that is avoid Trader
Joe's
[Laughter]
before I let you go carry champion we
have a game here on the Rich Eisen show
called start bench cut okay where we
give you we give you it's not on the
Titan games it's from and it's it's from
the mind of our rocks okay and you have
to start one bench one cut one okay so
you're given three choices you must
start bench cut let's do with carry
champion okay here we go first one up
for a carry champion UCLA Bruin in the
house the UCLA head coach you would want
hired you've got to have basketball okay
you've got it you've got to start one
bench one cut one Earl Watson who is
publicly endorsed by Alonso ball the
other night Fred Hoiberg who as we all
know did very well at Iowa State before
we all know what happened with the Bulls
and current Arizona has State head coach
Bobby Hurley is a hot head coach so
you'd have to start one bench one cut
one carry champion okay I start Earl
okay you start off I'd bench Hurley okay
and I cut homered what happened you
listen I don't I don't know if he has it
and I look what do I know I'm so when I
speak about the Bruins I'm speaking
completely out of sheer emotion and
that's what I think is there's a there's
a way that you need to connect with
these kids especially these Hollywood
kids and what I say by that is that a
lot of people who come to UCLA they have
a lot of star influence or they're
surrounded by stars yes roll can handle
that he's been there he played he like
he played there and he's a friend of
mine all right next one start bench cut
your favorite kind of ball tennis since
you're on the tennis channel okay basket
oh and then put it up right there on the
screen
levar wrench [ __ ] I am definitely
starting bassy because it is basketball
is my favorite sport because I will
bench it and I'm gonna have to cut you
the bar I am in more ways than one
I'm have to catch oh my gosh yeah I
don't promote violence no but I would if
I had to okay just seeing what it's like
on the set of the Titan
next up next up the exam we know you're
a Laker fan
oh my work across the street from
Staples every day great what a great
office you have haha on SportsCenter
most expendable and best Lakers trade
asset Lonzo Brandon Ingram Kyle Kuzma
start bench cut Carey champion this is
gonna get you know can I tell you
something no matter what I say here the
feedback is I'm gonna come to get it
never yes this is these are these are
not easy questions for a reason you're
gonna get by the way they get
increasingly more difficult they're
gonna add me they don't let me have it
at you listen at Carey champion yeah
tell me tell me how you feel I don't
care I'm gonna start Kyle I'm going to
bench Lonzo whoa and I'm cutting English
yeah can i we just had this conversation
today a lot Brent it's been three years
I need some development what who's
responsible for that I don't know I
guess there's not everyone's been around
long enough to start pointing fingers
but LeBron says he's a superstar LeBron
goes guess what he says he goes carry I
think he's a superstar I said do you
and then I same thing magic says the
same thing he's a superstar I mean I'm
doing these interviews with him and
they're telling me this kids a superstar
yeah because they want to train him come
on this is not your first rodeo
Carrie all right Anthony Davis we'll see
you in a minute all right last one last
one for for Kerry champion start bench
cut yeah best on-air co-host Oh Dwayne
Johnson Oh skip bayless that's your
bench cut I'm gonna cut myself
acceptable response Dwayne Johnson
Stevie Smith skip bayless stark bench
cut you know all I have to say is you
guys are not fair my kneecaps are sweaty
[Music]
okay okay
I'm going to I'm going to start DJ
obviously you're almost home I am going
to bench even a games on NBC Thursdays
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time Carrie
champion always the first of many times
to check it out folks please at 8:00
Eastern Time on Thursday nights that's
Carrie champion at Carrie champion so
after on Twitter you're in the Rich
Eisen the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience